Are you ready for the trip of a lifetime?
Because this not so little machine is about to take you on one,
a trip back in time.
What would you need for this time travel to happen?
How would it mess with your body and what do
black holes have to do with all this? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you built a tip blur time machine,
theoretically,
building a time-traveling device is possible or almost possible.
All you'd need to do is to assemble an enormous cylinder and get yourself for
spaceship.
Then you'd need to figure out how to make the cylinder spin at a few billion
rotations per minute.
And remember when I said it was enormous well for this cylinder to
work hits, length would need to be infinite.
Before I get into the explanation of how this time machine works.
Let me give you a bit of a backstory. In 1915,
Albert Einstein came up with his theory of general relativity.
He claimed that our universe can be described by four dimensions.
The first three would be the dimensions of space and the fourth would be
time together. Their space time,
gravity can bend space, time,
like a bowling ball would bend a rubber sheet.
The bending of space time makes time smooth.
The passage of time also changes depending on how fast you move.
The theory of general relativity blew people's minds.
But in 1974,
Frank Tiddler realized that solutions to equations of general relativity
could be used to build a time-traveling nice.
Now that you're all caught up, let's start building this machine already.
First.
You'd need to find material with the total mass of about 10 sons
where you'd find all that matter is a big question, of course,
but let's assume you manage to strip all the neighboring star systems and
assemble them into a cylinder somewhere above the earth.
10 solar masses worth of matter is no joke.
It would take up a lot of space and you would have to figure out how to compress
all that matter.
It would have to be so dense that it would turn into an elongated black hole.
There's no time to worry about getting sucked into it.
Now that you finally assembled a tickler cylinder,
you'd need to make it rotate at an unimaginably fast rate,
a few billion times every minute, theoretically,
instead of condensing a whole lot of matter into a black hole,
and then having to deal with the cylinder rotation.
You could just find a few neutron stars.
Those are leftovers from gigantic stars that didn't have enough mass
to collapse into black holes, and they rotate pretty fast.
You could line a few of them up and synchronize their rotation,
but even if you chose the fastest ones, their rotation,
wouldn't come close to a few billion times for a minute.
Besides we did an earlier video about trying to bring a spoonful of neutron
star back to earth, and it didn't
Anyway, regardless of how you achieve this effect,
the massive gravitational pull of the cylinder combined with the fast rotation
would create a frame dragging effect. In other words,
the cylinder would drag spacetime along with it.
That means that you could hop on a spacecraft and follow the spiral course of
the cylinder. And that would take you back in time.
Time would fold upon itself and you'd find yourself in a closed
timelike curve.
It's a loop in which you're traveling into the past has always been a part of
that past. So you wouldn't create any time paradoxes.
If you changed the direction of your travel, you'd go back to the future.
Or rather back to the time you started your journey from the tickler cylinder
specialty is travel into the past, not the future, but Hey,
you could hang out with your favorite people from the past,
go see a real life Jurassic world.
You could even go back to the time when the earth didn't have any life at all.
But of course there is a drawback. All that would only be possible.
If the tickler cylinder had an infinite length,
it would have to go on forever, but that's just impossible.
You can't build something that has no end at all.
If you tried to make a finite cylinder,
then you'd have to deal with some exotic matter and it's negative energy,
but we haven't discovered it yet.
And it doesn't look like we'll be getting our hands on this kind of matter.
Anytime soon,
I haven't even mentioned the effects of the black hole on your body.
You'd instantly get sucked into the cylinders black hole if you got close
enough,
but hopefully there are other ways that would allow you to travel through time.
And when you do,
we'll be there for you and help you survive this kind of trip on our new show,
how to survive.
[Inaudible].